copic vaccine requirements have arrived
but they're raising questions tonight
about vaccine exemptions thanks for
joining us at 11 i'm denise valdez and
i'm brian loftis so what are some
medical conditions that could prevent
people from getting vaccinated and what
about religious exemptions eight news
now's oracle mana is live tonight with
those answers
[Music]
well brian and denise a lot of people
are asking with fda approval will
exemptions from the coven 19 vaccine
still stand while medical experts say
that while there are no automatic
exemptions there are still certain
conditions that could make it more
difficult
the
biggest concern was obviously going into
anaphylactic chalk amanda favela has
serious allergic reactions but in terms
of protecting herself from covid19 my
doctor telling me you know please hold
off on getting the vaccine still favela
really wanted her shot and just got her
first dose with everything that was
happening with all the
you know vaccine mandates and whatnot it
kind of just i was like okay well
maybe i just gotta get it while favela
opted not to ask for a medical exemption
experts say her initial concerns were
valid and that would be if you actually
had an allergy
to a component of the vaccination even
if you have a doctor's medical exemption
from the covet vaccine you still might
have a hard time getting in to see the
raiders at allegiant stadium attending a
concert through live nation or being on
campus at unlv meanwhile churches are
grappling with religious exemptions the
church really walks a
fine line bishop gregory gordon with the
roman catholic diocese of las vegas says
they will not grant parishioners
religious exemptions for the covet
vaccine we
tell them to present that as a
conscientious
exemption that doesn't mean that they
have the right or we have the obligation
to provide a religious exemption it's
really a personal decision that's paid
off for favela i'm okay i've had my
first dose i'm okay
no experts say if you have a medical
issue and you are concerned about
getting the vaccine the best thing to do
is to consult a doctor reporting live in
las vegas tonight orgomana 8 news now